[MUSIC PLAYING]
KYLE MCDONALD: Hey, I'm Kyle.
MANNY TAN: I'm Manny.
YOTAM MANN: Hi, I'm Yotam.
This is something we made called
the Infinite Drum Machine.
[PERCUSSIVE SOUNDS]
It's basically an experiment to
see how machine learning might
organize everyday sounds.
So anyone who's ever had
to work with a lot of sound
can see why this is hard.
For example, we can all hear
that this is similar to this,
but totally different from this.
But it's hard to
articulate exactly why,
because sounds are complicated.
But this is the kind
of thing the machine
learning is really good at.
So we ran a little test.
We played thousands of
sounds for the computer.
We didn't give it descriptions,
or tags, or any hints on how
people usually organize sound.
We wanted instead to see
if it could listen to them,
and automatically learn its
own way to organize them.
KYLE MCDONALD: This experiment
uses a technique called t-SNE.
First, the computer
creates a fingerprint
from each sample,
which is like an image,
or a set of numbers
that represents
that particular sound.
Then t-SNE compares
all the fingerprints,
and places similar
sounds closer together.
One way to think about
t-SNE, is that it's
taking these fingerprints from
high-dimensional space, which
means a space with more
than three dimensions,
and reducing them.
In this case, to two dimensions,
so that we can visualize it.
MANNY TAN: And our
test basically worked.
This is the t-SNE that we got.
We put it on the web so
anyone can play with it.
You get these neighborhoods
of similar sounds
that you can explore
by dragging around.
[PERCUSSIVE SOUNDS]
And make beats with them
using this drum machine.
[PERCUSSIVE SOUNDS]
We're hoping people find
it fun, whether you're
more into the machine learning
side or more into making music.
You can play with it and get
the code at g.co/aiexperiments.